This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Barely a week after assuming office, President Donald Trump set off a worldwide firestorm when he decided to temporarily ban migrants from seven Muslim-majority countries and refugees from all over the world from entering the United States. I'm establishing new vetting measures to keep radical Islamic terrorists out of the United States of America. We don't want them here. We only want to admit those into our country who will support our country and love deeply our people.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。唐纳德·特朗普总统上任仅仅一周左右，就决定暂时禁止七个穆斯林人口占多数的国家的移民以及世界各地的难民进入美国，从而引发了一场全球风暴。我正在制定新的审查措施，将激进的伊斯兰恐怖分子拒之美国门外。我们不希望他们来这里。我们只想接纳那些支持我们国家、深爱我们人民的人。
Trump's executive order was greeted with support in some quarters. President Trump came in here not just as a commander in chief for the military. He's a CEO and he's trying to protect everybody in the country. And he's trying to keep everybody all-americ as regardless of religion, safe from the potential terrorist to come in. I mean, some people from some of these parts of the world believe it or not want to kill us. And with dismay and outrage in others. Spontaneous protests erupted at airports
特朗普的行政命令在某些圈子里受到了支持。特朗普总统来这里不仅仅是以三军统帅的身份。他是一名首席执行官，他正试图保护国内的每一个人。他正试图让每一个全美洲人——无论宗教信仰如何——免受潜在恐怖分子的伤害。我的意思是，信不信由你，来自这些世界某些地方的一些人确实想要杀死我们。而在其他地方，则充满了沮丧和愤怒。全国各地的机场和公共广场上
and public squares across the nation. You've got an obligation and a duty to do what? Resist! Resist! Resist! Resist! One technique we often use to understand current events is to look to the past, to see what history can teach us.
爆发了自发抗议活动。你们有义务和职责去做什么？抵抗！抵抗！抵抗！抵抗！我们经常用来理解时事的一种技术是回顾过去，看看历史能教给我们什么。
But this is a process that is fraught with psychological peril. We're often inclined to draw lessons from history that suit our preconceived notions of how to think about the present. Historians say there are important lessons that we can draw from the past, but there are also dangers to overly neat analogies. One analogy that many people have reached for in recent days is the story of the SS St. Louis. It's a notable story, drawn from the Holocaust, that is revealing in how we respond
但这是一个充满心理风险的过程。我们常常倾向于从历史中汲取符合我们对现状的先入为主观念的教训。历史学家表示，我们可以从过去中汲取重要的教训，但过度完美的类比也存在危险。近年来许多人想到的一个类比是“圣路易斯”号客轮的故事。这是一个引人注目的故事，取材于大屠杀，它揭示了我们如何应对
to the pleas of people fleeing distant shores for the United States. Many people might be familiar with the story of the St. Louis. On today's Hidden Brain, we're going to revisit that story and explore how it speaks to the current mood and anxieties of the United States. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Debra Lipstad is a professor of religion at Emory University. She is a historian who studied the Holocaust and how the United States and other countries dealt with the plight of Jewish refugees fleeing Nazi Germany in the 1930s and 40s. When a photograph recently circled the globe showing a three-year-old child lying face
逃离远方海岸前往美国的难民的恳求。很多人可能对“圣路易斯”号的故事很熟悉。在今天的Hidden Brain中，我们将重新审视这个故事，并探讨它如何反映了当前美国的情绪和焦虑。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。黛博拉·利普施塔特是埃默里大学的宗教教授。她是一位历史学家，专门研究大屠杀以及美国和其他国家在20世纪30年代和40年代如何应对逃离纳粹德国的犹太难民的困境。当一张照片最近传遍全球，显示一个三岁儿童面朝
down on a beach in Turkey, the boy and his family had drowned as they tried to escape the conflict in Turkey. The boy and his family had drowned as they tried to escape the conflict in Syria. Debra Lipstead wrote, seeing the child's lifeless body washed up on a beach, who among us does not wonder, is history repeating itself. Debra Lipstead, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. In May 1939, Debra, a German passenger ship left Hamburg with about 900 passengers. The ship, the SS St. Louis, made a stop in France, picked up a few more passengers. Most of the passengers were hoping to get to the United States.
下趴在土耳其的海滩上时，这个男孩和他的家人在试图逃离土耳其的冲突时溺水身亡。这个男孩和他的家人在试图逃离叙利亚的冲突时溺水身亡。黛博拉·利普施塔特写道，看到这个孩子毫无生气的尸体被冲上沙滩，我们当中有谁不会想，历史是否正在重演。黛博拉·利普施塔特，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢。1939年5月，黛博拉，一艘德国客轮载着大约900名乘客离开了汉堡。这艘船，即“圣路易斯”号，在法国作了停留，接上了一些乘客。大多数乘客都希望能去美国。
Tell me who these passengers were, who were they, and why were they on that ship? Most of them were German nationals, German Jews, who had faced terrible persecution. So it was people from all over Germany who were desperate, desperate, desperate, desperate to get out of Germany. Do we know anything about the stories of individual passengers aboard the ship? Well, I think there were all sorts. There was one who was, I think, Gisele Feldman. She was 15 years old.
告诉我这些乘客都是谁，他们是谁，他们为什么会在那艘船上？他们大多数是德国国民、德国犹太人，曾遭受过可怕的迫害。所以他们是来自德国各地、迫不及待、急切地想要离开德国的人。我们对船上个别乘客的故事了解多少？嗯，我认为各种各样的人都有。其中一个我想是吉塞尔·费尔德曼。她当时15岁。
Her mother was married to a Polish Jew who had been in Germany for many years. He had been ejected from Germany in October 38. The mother was desperate to get out with Gisele and her sister, and though the father begged the mother to please wait till he came back from Poland, she said, I must take my daughters to safety, and that was one family that was on the boat. And then there was a six-year-old Saul messenger who was traveling with his father and his mother, and he also, these were all people, different classes, different economic status, different educational
她的母亲嫁给了一位在德国生活多年的波兰犹太人。他在38年10月被驱逐出德国。母亲迫切希望带着吉塞尔和她的妹妹离开，尽管父亲恳求母亲等他从波兰回来，但她说，我必须带我的女儿们去安全的地方，那是船上的一个家庭。然后还有一个六岁的索尔·梅森杰，他和他的父母一起旅行，他也——这些人来自不同的阶层、不同的经济状况、不同的教育
background, but all people who saw this as a lifeline to getting out of Germany. So you have the ship of 900 Jewish passengers. It's important to mention, of course, that the SS St. Louis was a German ship. It was under Nazi command. How would the passengers treat treated aboard the ship? This is a remarkable part of the story. The captain, Captain Schroeder, who is really one of the heroes of this story, instructed his crew that these people were to be treated with the utmost respect as they would treat
背景，但所有人都将这视为离开德国的救命稻草。所以你们有一艘载有900名犹太乘客的船。当然，值得一提的是，“圣路易斯”号是一艘德国船只。它在纳粹的指挥下。船上的乘客受到了怎样的对待？这是故事中非常了不起的一部分。船长施罗德船长，他真的是这个故事中的英雄之一，指示他的船员，这些人必须受到最大的尊重，就像对待任何其他船上的乘客或像这样的船上的任何其他乘客一样。
passengers on any other ship or any other passengers on board a ship such as this. They were not to be in any way abused or mistreated. So you had ardennancy serving Jews and serving them, you know, the same meals that anybody in that class of service would have received. And what you hear and what's very often so poignant when you read the descriptions, even amongst the children, was the way the anxiety and the tension began to be stripped away as they were treated for the first time in seven years, six years as normal human beings. Slowly but surely, they relaxed. They talked about the fact that the captain allowed them to have Friday night services in the cinema or one of the gathering places on board ship and captain allowed them to have Friday night services in the cinema
他们绝不能受到以任何方式的虐待或不公正对待。所以你有狂热的纳粹分子为犹太人服务，为他们提供——你知道的，任何该服务等级的乘客都会得到的相同餐食。当你听到并且在阅读描述时经常感到非常辛酸的是，甚至在儿童当中，随着他们七年来、六年来第一次被当作正常的人类对待，焦虑和紧张情绪开始被剥离的方式。慢慢地、确凿地，他们放松了下来。他们谈论船长允许他们在电影院或船上的某个聚会场所举行周五晚上的礼拜，船长允许他们在电影院或船上的某个聚会场所举行周五晚上的礼拜
or one of the gathering places on board ship and even allowed them to put a tablecloth over the bus to Vadov Hitler, so they wouldn't be praying with the bus to Vadov Hitler looking on on them. And the children described swimming in the swimming pool, something that Jewish children hadn't been able to do for years. The plan was for the ship to sail to Cuba. Once in Havana, the passengers expected to wait until they could gain admission to the United States, but the Cubans didn't want them.
甚至允许他们在阿道夫·希特勒的半身像上盖上一块桌布，这样他们在祈祷时就不会被阿道夫·希特勒的半身像注视着。孩子们描述了在游泳池里游泳的情景，这是犹太儿童多年来一直无法做到的事情。该计划是让这艘船航行到古巴。一旦到达哈瓦那，乘客们预计要等待，直到他们能够获得进入美国的准许，但古巴人不想要他们。
The mood on the St. Louis changed immediately, from Jubilant to deeply dejected. The ship headed for Miami. The passengers did not have US travel documents, but this was their only hope. The US Holocaust Memorial Museum interviewed survivors. In 1989, one woman, Gerta Blackman-Wilkfort, described the mood after leaving Cuba. Gerta and her parents were passengers on the St. Louis. She was just a teenager.
“圣路易斯”号上的气氛立刻从欢欣鼓舞变成了深深的沮丧。这艘船驶向迈阿密。乘客们没有美国的旅行证件，但这是他们唯一的希望。美国大屠杀纪念馆采访了幸存者。1989年，一位名叫格尔达·布莱克曼-威尔克福特的女性描述了离开古巴后的心情。格尔达和她的父母是“圣路易斯”号上的乘客。她当时还只是个青少年。
Well, you can imagine that was terrible mood. Everybody was very depressed. A few people tried to commit suicide. I think, but in our humans, I always hope for. We always cling to the hope that something is going to happen. They're not going to let us rot on the ocean. I mean, something has to happen to us. So Deborah set the stage for us. The United States is not yet at war with Germany. World War II has not yet officially broken out.
嗯，你可以想象当时的心情糟透了。每个人都非常沮丧。少数人试图自杀。我想，但在我们人类心中，我总是心存希望。我们总是紧抓着某种事情会发生的希望。他们不会让我们在海洋上腐烂的。我的意思是，我们身上一定会发生点什么。所以黛博拉，为我们奠定背景。美国尚未与德国交战。第二次世界大战尚未正式爆发。
American public sentiment against Hitler is quite strong at this point. And the United States is admitting Jewish refugees. But I'm wondering what kind of conversations were happening in Washington, in people's homes? Did ordinary Americans care, as Gorda says, if passengers on the St. Louis actually rotted on the ocean? The truth of the matter is that America at this point was still strongly isolationist.
此时美国公众对希特勒的反感相当强烈。美国正在接纳犹太难民。但我在想，华盛顿、人们的家中都在进行什么样的谈话？正如格尔达所说，“圣路易斯”号上的乘客如果在海洋上真正腐烂了，普通美国人会在乎吗？事实的真相是，此时的美国仍然具有强烈的孤立主义倾向。
America first, the movement with which Charles Lindbergh was very closely associated. Lindbergh, of course, being famous for having flown over the Atlantic. But there was a strong, not only isolation is sentiment in America, but there was also a strong anti-immigrant sentiment. I think one study showed that 83% of Americans were opposed
美国优先，查尔斯·林德伯格与之密切相关的运动。当然，林德伯格因飞越大西洋而闻名。但美国不仅存在强烈的孤立主义情绪，还存在强烈的反移民情绪。我想一项研究表明，83%的美国人反对
to relaxing immigration restrictions. And even more than being anti-immigrant was also anti-refugee because being an immigrant was bad enough, but it meant you could go back to some place. If you were a refugee, generally it meant you weren't going back. And coupled with that, America, there was a strong anti-Semitic sentiment in America. You know, sometimes we think the enemy of my enemy is my friend. Well, that wasn't the case here. What was really happening was that people felt you don't want them. We don't want them either. The historian David Wyman talks about how US officials kept out foreigners by erecting
放松移民限制。比反移民更甚的是反难民，因为身为移民已经够糟糕了，但这意味着你还可以回到某个地方。如果你是一个难民，通常这意味着你回不去了。再加上这一点，美国存在着强烈的反犹太主义情绪。你知道，有时我们认为敌人的敌人就是朋友。嗯，这里可不是这样。真正发生的事情是，人们觉得你们不想要他们。我们也不想要他们。历史学家大卫·怀曼谈到美国官员如何通过建立
what he calls paper walls, bureaucratic barriers to entry. But of course, Deborah, these walls are coming in the context of the Great Depression, which had ended only a few years earlier. Many Americans were worried about their livelihoods, about immigrants taking their jobs. In fact, I believe there were people who said, yes, we want to be compassionate to children who are refugees. But in a few years, those refugee children are going to be adults and they're going to be competing with us for jobs.
他所谓的纸质壁垒——官僚主义的入境障碍——来把外国人拒之门外。但当然，黛博拉，这些壁垒是在大萧条的背景下出现的，而大萧条仅仅在几年前才结束。许多美国人担心他们的生计，担心移民抢走他们的工作。事实上，我相信有人说，是的，我们希望对作为难民的儿童表现出同情。但在几年内，那些难民儿童将成为成年人，他们将与我们竞争工作岗位。
That's exactly right. Look, there were a number of things that helped set the scene in America. First of all, there was the great depression so that you looked at every refugee, every person entering this country as a job competitor. On top of that, you had a terrible xenophobia in America, a fear of the foreigner, a fear of the refugee, a fear of someone who was different. And these were Jewish refugees, and there was on top of that xenophobia was tremendous anti-Semitism. This was a period in the United States of terrific racism, the Ku Klux Klan, but coupled with that, there was also a great deal of anti-Semitism.
完全正确。看，有许多因素共同构成了美国的背景。首先是大萧条，因此你把每一个难民、每一个进入这个国家的人都视为工作竞争对手。除此之外，美国还存在可怕的仇外心理，对外国人的恐惧，对难民的恐惧，对与众不同的人的恐惧。而这些都是犹太难民，在这种仇外心理之上还有巨大的反犹太主义。这是美国种族主义猖獗的时期，有三K党，但除此之外，还有大量的反犹太主义。
And finally, the third factor, which I think is very important, is isolationism, the fear that these people coming here were going to drag us into a war. And America's first international beyond the American continent involvement had been what was then called the Great War, what we today call a World War I. And Americans had felt we got involved, look what's going on in Europe in the 15, 20 years since we were involved. Nothing has really changed. You have Stalin, you have Hitler, you have Mussolini, you know, Fulmy once, get me involved
最后是第三个因素，我认为非常重要，那就是孤立主义，担心这些人来到这里会把我们拖入战争。美国在美洲大陆以外的第一次国际参与是当时被称为“伟大战争”的冲突，也就是我们今天所说的一次世界大战。美国人觉得我们卷入了战争，看看自从我们卷入以来这15、20年里欧洲发生了什么。没有什么真正改变。你有斯大林，你有希特勒，你有墨索里尼，你知道，富勒一次，让我卷入
once, shame on you, Fulmy twice, shame on me, we're not going to do this again. So when you put together those elements of the great depression, xenophobia, anti-Semitism, and isolationism, the refugees from Germany had tremendous hurdles to overcome. So you have to ship with 900 people off the US coast. The teenager got a work for it, describe what happened next. We just saw the coast got both surrounded by Miami to make sure that we wouldn't even
一次，那是你的耻辱；富勒两次，那是我的耻辱，我们绝不再做这种事了。因此，当你把大萧条、仇外心理、反犹太主义和孤立主义这些元素结合在一起时，来自德国的难民有巨大的障碍需要克服。所以你们有一艘载有900人的船停在美国海岸。那个十几岁的女孩格尔达·威尔克福特描述了接下来发生的事情。我们刚看到海岸周围都被迈阿密包围了，以确保我们甚至不会
come close to shore so it was out. We saw the lights of Miami, we saw the lights of America, and that was it. When we come back, we look at what's happening today and how it does and doesn't echo the past. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedenthan. After leaving Havana and setting off the coast of Miami for several days, the St. Louis was eventually turned back to Europe.
靠近海岸，所以没戏了。我们看到了迈阿密的灯光，我们看到了美国的灯光，就是这样。当我们回来时，我们将审视今天发生了什么，以及它如何与过去呼应或不呼应。请继续收听。这里是Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在离开哈瓦那并在迈阿密海岸徘徊数日后，“圣路易斯”号最终被遣返回欧洲。
Past and years was scattered among several European countries. Several hundred were eventually killed by the Nazis. Gurdah and her mother escaped to Switzerland, but her father was not so lucky. I'm speaking today with Deborah Lipipsdatt, a professor of religion at Emory University. There were some who believed that the consequences of rejecting the St. Louis were felt not just by the passengers on board the ship. It's worth pointing out that the Nazis actually wanted Jews deported from Germany in the late 1930s, but once you had experiences like the St. Louis, German officials reconsidered
过去几年里，乘客们分散在几个欧洲国家。几百人最终被纳粹杀害。格尔达和她的母亲逃到了瑞士，但她的父亲就没有那么幸运了。我今天与埃默里大学的宗教教授黛博拉·利普施塔特进行交谈。有些人认为，拒绝“圣路易斯”号的后果不仅由船上的乘客承担。值得指出的是，纳粹实际上在20世纪30年代末希望将犹太人从德国驱逐出去，但一旦你有了像“圣路易斯”号这样的经历，德国官员就重新考虑了
the possibility of deporting large numbers of Jews from Germany and German occupied Europe. So Debrit, did the voyage of the St. Louis play a role in the German decision to implement what came to be called the final solution? It's hard to trace a direct line from the decision to reject the ship to the final solution. I don't know that we can do that, but we certainly can say that this was a propaganda coup for the Germans, because they were able to say, everyone is mad at us for not wanting the Jews, no one else seems to want them either. So sometime ago, Deborah, you wrote about the current refugee crisis and asked, is history
从德国和德国占领的欧洲驱逐大量犹太人的可能性。那么黛博拉，“圣路易斯”号的航行是否在德国决定实施后来被称为“最终解决方案”的行动中发挥了作用？很难从拒绝该船的决定直接追溯到最终解决方案。我不知道我们能否做到这一点，但我们肯定可以说，这对德国人来说是一次宣传政变，因为他们能够说，每个人都因为我们不想要犹太人而对我们生气，而且似乎也没有其他人想要他们。所以一段时间以前，黛博拉，你写了关于当前难民危机的文章，并问道：历史是在重演吗？是这样吗？
repeating itself? Is it? You know, I asked that, I wrote that a while back and I'm reluctant. Since then, there have been so many glib comparisons to history, so many glib comparisons. This is just like Hitler, this is just like Mussolini, this is just like Germany and 33, 38, whatever. I don't know if history is repeating itself. I deal with the past when it's already happened, you know? But I do think that there are some very ominous signs on the horizon and ominous sentiments certainly in the United States but not only
你知道，我问过这个问题，我前段时间写过，而且我很勉强。从那时起，有太多对历史的肤浅比较，太多的肤浅比较。这就像希特勒，这就像墨索里尼，这就像33年、38年的德国，等等。我不知道历史是否在重演。我只在过去已经发生时才处理过去，你知道吗？但我确实认为，地平线上有一些非常不祥的征兆，而且肯定在美国、但不仅在美国也有不祥的情绪，这些情绪把我们带离了我们国家建立时的理想非常遥远。
in the United States which take us very far away from the ideals on which our country was founded. I want to think about the uses of history in the present and I want to be careful about two potential pitfalls and one is over interpreting, and the other is under-interpreting history. So let's just do the first one first. You know, there are people who would use history as a cudgel to score political points. And especially when that history is about Hitler and the Holocaust, it's very difficult to draw analogies without sounding like you're leveling very, very serious accusations. I was speaking yesterday with Sarah Oglevi at the US Holocaust Memorial Museum.
我想思考历史在当下的用途，并且我想小心避免两个潜在的陷阱，一个是过度解读历史，另一个是对历史解读不足。所以我们先来做第一个。你知道，有些人会把历史当作大棒来争取政治积分。特别是当这段历史涉及希特勒和大屠杀时，要在不听起来像是提出非常非常严重指控的情况下进行类比是非常困难的。我昨天与美国大屠杀纪念馆的萨拉·奥格尔维进行了交谈。
She is the co-author of the book Refuge Denied about the Void of the St. Louis. As you reminded me, it was important to keep nuances in mind. ISIS and the Syrian Civil War are not identical to Hitler and the Third Reich. Many of the refugees fleeing today are fleeing from Third countries. They've made it out of war zones. Some are seeking economic opportunity and not just physical safety. So there is a risk in sort of over interpreting history and saying what happened with the St. Louis is exactly what's happening today.
她是关于“圣路易斯”号航行的书《被拒绝的避难所》的合著者。正如你提醒我的那样，记住细微差别非常重要。伊斯兰国和叙利亚内战与希特勒和第三帝国并不完全相同。今天逃离的许多难民是从第三国逃出来的。他们逃离了战区。有些人是为了寻求经济机会，而不仅仅是人身安全。因此，过度解读历史，说“圣路易斯”号发生的事情就是今天发生的事情，是存在风险的。
The refugee crisis we're seeing today is not the same as the Holocaust. What happened in Aleppo was horrific. Civilians were purposely targeted. Schools were targeted. Hospitals were purposely targeted, schools were targeted, hospitals were targeted, markets were targeted, but it wasn't a Holocaust. Having said that, and I wanna make this explicitly clear, I'm not saying that therefore we should not respond. I think it's our obligation,
我们今天看到的难民危机与大屠杀并不相同。阿勒颇发生的事情是可怕的。平民被蓄意攻击。学校被蓄意攻击，医院被蓄意攻击，市场被蓄意攻击，但这不是大屠杀。话虽如此，我想明确这一点，我并不是说因此我们不应该做出反应。我认为这是我们的义务，
in each generation we face crises, they don't have to be akin to a Holocaust for us to respond. No one should say, oh, it's not a Holocaust. Wake me when it's a Holocaust. Because if you wake someone then it's too late to do anything. You know, and that brings us to the idea of under interpreting history. After the Holocaust, we said, you know, never forget, but if never forget means that we will only pay attention when the lives of Jews are at risk, or we have someone like Hitler in charge of a major country, then that essentially means that there really is no likely application for history to the present time. And it seems
在每一代人中我们都面临危机，它们不必类似于大屠杀我们才去应对。没有人应该说：“哦，这不是大屠杀。等它是大屠杀时再叫醒我。”因为如果你到那时才叫醒某人，做任何事都太晚了。你知道，这把我们引向了对历史解读不足的想法。大屠杀后，我们说，你知道，永不忘记，但如果永不忘记意味着我们只在犹太人的生命受到威胁时才关注，或者当我们有像希特勒这样的人掌管一个大国时才关注，那么这基本上意味着历史在当代实际上没有任何可能的应用。并且似乎
like that's not really learning very much from the lessons of history. It's a very delicate balance. I don't study history and teach history only because I'm interested in arcane facts of what happened in the past. I obviously believe that history has something to teach us, but I'm also modest in judgment of drawing simple parallels because then you tend to get lib and then you tend to flatten out differences. At the same time, I think it's wrong to ignore certain tendencies, to ignore certain behaviors, to ignore leaders who see themselves in a certain way or act in a certain way,
这并没有真正从历史教训中学到多少东西。这是一个非常微妙的平衡。我研究历史和教授历史不仅是因为我对过去发生的晦涩事实感兴趣。我显然相信历史有东西要教给我们，但对于得出简单平行的判断我也很谨慎，因为这样你往往会变得肤浅，然后你往往会抹平差异。与此同时，我认为忽视某些倾向、忽视某些行为、忽视那些以某种方式看待自己或以某种方式行事的领导人是错误的，
whether in our country, whether in Europe, you see it in many different places. That, and their behavior is reminiscent of leaders in the past who went on to do very terrible things, both to their own people and to other countries, inhabitants of other countries. So it's a balance. And speaking about today's situation and comparing it to the 1930s, I'm start with the 1930s. I grew up, you know, amongst many refugees from Hitler, I grew up on the Upper West Side of Manhattan. I never saw in my lifetime, more loyal citizens to the United States, people whose devotion to the United States of America was overwhelming.
无论在我国，还是在你在许多不同地方看到的欧洲。这一点，以及他们的行为让人想起过去那些对本国人民和其他国家、其他国家居民做出非常可怕事情的领导人。所以这是一个平衡。说到今天的情况并将其与20世纪30年代进行比较，我从20世纪30年代开始。我是在希特勒统治下的许多难民中长大的，我是在曼哈顿上西区长大的。在我的一生中，我从未见过比这更忠于美国的公民，人们对美洲合众国的奉献是压倒性的。
I remember some of those people during the late 60s and the Vietnam uprising and when my generation which thought it knew everything was telling our parents what was wrong with this country, they're pain. And it wasn't the blind loyalty, but it was a love and a devotion that sometimes the person who was born into that country may not have to the same extent. So, you know, they love this country, they love the United States with a passion because the United States had rescued them. And I think that sometimes reaching out to people and showing them the best of who we are, not in a stupid fashion and not in a thoughtless fashion, in a careful, vetted fashion will do more to win loyalties than throwing up barriers
我记得在60年代末和越南起义期间，当时我们这一代人自以为无所不知，正在告诉我们的父母这个国家有什么问题时，他们的痛苦。这并不是盲目的忠诚，而是一种有时在那个国家出生的人可能无法同等感受到的爱和奉献。所以，你知道，他们热爱这个国家，他们充满激情地热爱美国，因为美国拯救了他们。而且我认为有时向人们伸出援手并向他们展示我们最好的一面——不是以愚蠢的方式，也不是以轻率的方式，而是以谨慎、经过审查的方式——比筑起墙壁更能赢得忠诚
to everyone. Many of the passengers on the St. Louis were saved because individuals and non-governmental organizations stepped forward to do the right thing. Many people of course looked to governments to provide the lead, but it seems to me that one of the potential historical lessons of the potential historical lessons of the St. Louis is that if you care about refugees, you could step up to act, even if you feel your government is not doing so. I agree 100%. You know, I read many stories these past few days of people or even past weeks.
面向所有人。“圣路易斯”号上的许多乘客得以获救，是因为个人和非政府组织挺身而出做正确的事。当然，许多人指望政府来带头，但在我看来，“圣路易斯”号潜在的历史教训之一是，如果你关心难民，即使你觉得你的政府没有这样做，你也可以挺身而出采取行动。百分之百同意。你知道，过去几天甚至过去几周，我读到了许多关于人们的故事。
People going to airports with clothing and with toys for arriving children. And on some level, I thought, well, this is a great gift for the people arriving, because most of them are arriving with nothing. It's also a tremendous gift to the people who are doing it. They feel so good about what they're doing. It's hands on good deeds, it's hands on justice, it's hands on opening your arms to the stranger. We shouldn't open our arms to the strangers blindly, we should be careful, but we shouldn't say just because they're strangers, they're a threat, just because they're strangers, they're a danger to us.
人们带着衣物和玩具前往机场迎接到达的儿童。在某种程度上，我认为，这对到达的人来说是一份厚礼，因为他们大多数人到达时一无所有。这也是对那些这样做的人的一大恩赐。他们对自己的所作所为感到非常高兴。这是亲力亲为的善行，这是亲力亲为的正义，这是向陌生人敞开双臂。我们不应该盲目地向陌生人敞开双臂，我们应该小心，但我们不应该仅仅因为他们是陌生人就说他们是威胁，仅仅因为他们是陌生人就说他们对我们构成了危险。
Debra Lipsstad is a professor of religion at Emory University. Debra, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for giving me a chance to talk about these crucial topics. I really appreciate it. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman and Raina Cohen. Our staff includes Chloe Connelly and Renee Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Special thanks this week to Russell Newlove at the BBC. Our run song here today is NPR Science Editor and Goodencoff.
黛博拉·利普施塔特是埃默里大学的宗教教授。黛博拉，谢谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢你给我机会谈论这些至关重要的话题。我真的很感激。本期Hidden Brain由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和雷娜·科恩制作。我们的员工包括克洛伊·康纳利和蕾妮·克拉尔。我们的主管制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。本周特别感谢BBC的拉塞尔·新爱。我们今天的片尾曲是NPR科学编辑兼古登科夫。
Anne played a central role in developing Hidden Brain on the radio and has been a powerful force in shaping all of public radio science journalism. And hates to be in the spotlight, so along with saying thank you, I'm going to say, I'm sorry. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this show, please tell a friend and tell us whom you've tapped on social media. We're always looking for new people to find our show. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安在电台Hidden Brain的发音发展中发挥了核心作用，并且一直是塑造所有公共广播科学新闻的强大力量。安讨厌成为聚光灯下的焦点，所以除了说谢谢，我要说，对不起。要了解更多Hidden Brain，您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并在您当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果您喜欢这个节目，请告诉您的朋友，并在社交媒体上告诉我们您标记了谁。我们一直在寻找新的人来发现我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。谢谢。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。